it's that easy
that's not a resolution that's just
something I want to do okay fine I can
do that
my resolution is need a loose woman
that's a good one if someone offers you
a cocktail except but keep your wits
about you please and thank you go a long
way copy
thank you thank you
please
what my place tonight wear this you have
your card yeah
don't forget the pipe what are you
wearing come on it's a casual social
outfit looks like you're going to a fish
fry Dwight no but how long at the moon
it's suggestive to women because of
howling during sex okay
it's not appropriate
I'm cool I'm cool
[Music]
okay okay come on let's go oh
everything cell phone charger yeah
so sure you don't want breakfast it's
the most important meal of the day it
really is I'm not hungry I ate a whole
bunch of sunflower seeds after you went
to sleep and besides I wouldn't want to
take you away from Pam on the morning of
our wedding what she needs you Isabelle
that's really sweet Dwight
okay get out of here bye okay
it's about damn time I haven't gone to
the bathroom in a day and a half oh my
God Dwight this
really hadn't noticed too busy knocking
boots
how can you eat like that
I'm ravenous after a night of love
making you
yeah I'm hungry but I'm not gonna make a
pig why would you like
she was cute you know she was hot she
was very hot
she made love like a tiger right side or
groom side or Towny
she was from Europe
an hairy armpits no Isabel was nice but
I hope she doesn't think this is going
anywhere
wait a second you're not into her are
you kidding me oh she's Pam's best
friend you guys could double date
swap maybe oh please put a gun in my
mouth no you're crazy look she's a
dental hygienist from Carbondale and she
makes love like one she's a bumpkin pad
thank you oh I got it the party playing
committee
what about that meeting
later
to discuss finances
yes
I'm hungry
put your forehead near mine and see if
you can read my thoughts
seven one one
nine no not numbers no no okay
I'm still getting number seven one one
is anyone around here thinking the
number 711
please stop okay Dwight give me a key
card to your room
meet me in seven minutes for someone on
one time wait the numbers
oh see you in seven seven minutes
Nelly wait
let me write my room number on the card
win at all costs don't respect women
these are the tenants I was brought up
with and they have served me well
my ancestors never worked in Corporate
America
for farmers and before that hunters and
before that time travelers and before
that me again at least that's how the
legend goes the point is they never had
to worry about how they got ahead they
just had to put food on the table and
not alter the past
second best Bananas Foster I've ever had
well what's the first best
too nice to go twice
hello
twice
are you in there
I can see the light on under your door
hello
[Music]
oh look at that the light went off just
as I said the light went off
hello
Dwight
oh
what is my Perfect Crime
I break into Tiffany's at midnight
do I go for the vault no I go for the
chandelier it's Priceless as I'm taking
it down a woman catches me she tells me
to stop it's her father's business she's
Tiffany I say no we make love all night
in the morning the cops come and I
escape in one of their uniforms I tell
her to meet me in Mexico but I go to
Canada I don't trust her besides I like
the cold
30 years later I get a postcard I have a
son and he's the chief of police this is
where the story gets interesting I tell
Tiffany to meet me in Paris by the
Trocadero
she's been waiting for me all these
years she's never taken another lover I
don't care I don't show up I go to
Berlin that's where I stashed the
chandelier
hey Isabel you made it oh my course you
want to play pool
um I'm gonna do a lap see if I know
anyone okay and then they said the most
ridiculous thing about Anderson Cooper
which I do not have the decency to
repeat but trust me when I tell you that
well that's right
well well well
it isn't Isabelle
it's a girl like you doing in a place
like this a girl like me as well a guy
like you comes to a face like this
do you
think there's a battle scene coming
oh air hockey basketball we could play
that
oh whack-a-mole brothers or sisters
Three Brothers really so we're in the
Marines one's a cup vegetarian
no I love meat
what's your blood type oh negative
universal donor universal donor
Angela versus Isabel
height Advantage Isabel birthing hips
Advantage Isabel remaining child bearing
years Advantage Isabel
legal obligation
Advantage Angelo this move he can't get
you well I think that he could counter
that move this Grand Strangler is a
professional Strangler oh please I wish
he'd come after me I would be like
Dwight Kurt true you are hereby served
with this summons to appear in
Lackawanna County Court
what are you talking about what are you
Dwight recently entered into a contract
with me establishing intent to conceive
and raise a child with me did he not
tell you that it really brought me in an
awkward position here
do you plan on raising a child with me
or do you plan on breaking this contract
not Dwight
whack
[Music]
you will see me in small claims court
you are an impressive specimen thank you
[Applause]
I love you
and I don't care that Philip's not my
son I will raise a hundred children with
a hundred of your lovers if it means I
can be with you
can you put that down physics stretches
how loudly I love you
this is a ring
taken from the buttocks of my
grandmother
put there by the gangster patriarch of
the Coors Dynasty
melted in a Foundry run by Mennonites
okay yeah
yeah
I love you I love you
and I lied to you what
Phillips your son what why would you say
that I just needed you to want to marry
me because you wanted to marry me
get out
I'm a dad you're a dad